I'm still trying to process what just
happened in this game but let's get into
it I was playing Shard gagar from
India and coming into this game I
actually had a lot of time to prepare
because yesterday was a rest day but
instead of like pouring over opening
Theory yesterday I did a lot of
non-chest things uh I went
bowling
I played some ping
pong had some Thai food and I only
started preparing for my opponent this
morning I really just took the day off
yesterday from chess and this morning I
looked at my opponent's games and saw
that he's capable of playing E4 and D4
and C4 and F3 so I really didn't know
what what to expect coming into this
game but I found out soon enough what
opening he would go for and once the
game began uh he played Pawn to D4 and
we went into a Queen's Gambit declined
and in this position I saw that he's
been playing a lot of Catan with G3 so
this is what I was uh more expecting but
he went for Knight C3 which of course is
also very playable and in this position
I've played a lot of different moves uh
I've played C6 I've played Bishop E7
I've taken on C4 uh there's Rock goes in
I've played A6 recently but the line I
went for is Knight B D7 uh this is
called the barmin variation and it's one
of my pet lines and it leads to just a
lot of different types of uh structures
depending what white plays so it's
really a way to try and get a fresh
position from early on so here my
opponent took on D5 I take back and he
plays Bishop to G5 uh this is one of the
more standard ways of playing uh black
is in some cases threatening to take on
D5 so I play C6 solidifying the center
he plays E3 and I go for H6 and I am
still in preparation here and after
Bishop H4 I played the move Pawn to G5
and this is not a typical occurrence in
these Queen Gambit decline structures
where black goes for the quick H6 G5
but this is a variation I discovered
about a year ago and the more I looked
into it the more excited I became about
it because it's just a waight imbalance
a position early and the idea is after
Bishop G3 I very quickly play Knight H5
and black is guaranteed to get the
bishop pair here so I was happy to
basically play this over the board for
the first time now my opponent here
played Queen to C2 I took on G3 he takes
and I played Bishop Bishop to G7 and
here there's a few different options for
white I think the main move is Bishop to
D3 and then white can stay flexible and
choose whether to Castle King side or
queen side but here my opponent chose to
Castle Queen side right away and from
here I still kind of knew the the basic
plan for black is generally when White
Castles Queen side and leaves a rook on
H1 then black definitely doesn't want a
castle King side and my plan here is to
eventually Castle Queen side and I
basically knew the ideal setup is Knight
B6 Bishop E6 Queen E7 and Castle long so
I started with Knight D6 and I was
expecting my opponent to play Bishop D3
which is definitely the most natural
developing move but my opponent thought
for almost 10 minutes here before
playing a very explosive move Pawn to E4
uh a small correction it was way more
than 10 minutes uh almost like 15 to 20
minutes to play Pawn E4 and this
definitely surprised me and um I was
definitely not specifically prepared for
this variation uh and generally E4 is
not a great break for white because
black has a bishop pair and in general
when one side has a bishop pair and
there's some Pawn trades then the two
Bishops become very happy uh but the
reason why my opponent went for E4 is my
king is still in the center so there's
some pros and cons for playing this
break on one hand it does favor the
Bishops but on the other hand it's
trying to exploit my king which is still
uh kind of far away from getting safe on
the queen side and yeah in this position
I took my first extended think of the
game and I was mainly deciding between
taking on e4 and playing Bishop E6 and I
was close to playing Bishop E6 but I did
didn't want to allow white to play E5
and just get a nice looking space
Advantage a more closed position where
my Bishops aren't so impressive and the
Knights are probably
preferable so after my think I did
decide to take on e4 and after Knight
takes E4 I played the move Queen to
D5 and uh yeah this looks like a
somewhat of a risky move because yeah my
queen is out in the open but I was
trying to Target the A2 pawn and I
should note here that I wanted to play
Bishop E6 which is maybe a more natural
uh developing move but I didn't like the
prospect of Knight to C5 and I thought
if white gets this move in then my
bishop and my Pawn are attacked Rook E1
is coming and I didn't see a great way
to make this line work for black so I
play Queen D5 and now the idea is if
white plays a move like Rook E1 setting
up some discoveries then I can play
Bishop E6 and I don't think white has
time for Knight C5 because then I can
snag the a pawn and yeah there should be
uh lot of nice active play for black in
that position the queen would still
defend the Bishop from a
distance so instead of Rook E1 my
opponent played Knight C3 and I want to
note that my opponent was spending a lot
of time like took a lot of time to play
E4 and took about 25 minutes
to play this move Knight C3 um but this
is a move I was expecting because it's
very natural to attack the queen defend
the pawn and get ready to play Rook E1
check so I get out the way I play Queen
A5 and he plays Rook to E1 I play Bishop
to E6 and in this position I was feeling
good I thought that if I get one more
move in the castling Queen side then
I'll just have a an amazing setup with
the two Bishops um especially this
bishop aimed at White's isolated Queen's
pawn and just really harmonious uh
pieces all around so I I thought that
things are looking pretty good for me
not only based on the position but also
time situation I'm up about uh 35
minutes on the clock but my opponent
here played a move which I think is
called for and it's by far the most
aggressive move in the position is Rook
takes
E6 and in this moment I do want to
apologize
for what I did in the last video I think
I I scared a lot of people with Levy's
uh sacrifice a rook clip uh inter
dispersed in in my commentary a lot of
people were complaining in the comments
so not going to do that in this video
but anyway my opponent did sacrifice the
rook and the idea is after Pawn takes
there's Queen Queen
G6 and um yeah I'm definitely on the
back foot because white is attacking the
bishop and the king and the pawn had to
play King f8 to
defend and um yeah here my opponent took
a a long time to take the pawn on E6 and
note now that my opponent used almost
all his time to to get to this position
has just over 6 minutes left and I have
an hour to try and figure out what's
going on I do have the material
advantage I am up a rook for Knight and
pawn but the position is far from simple
and yeah I have to figure out what to do
now I want to pause here before we go
forward with the game because there's
something super super surprising that
I'm I'm still trying to process and it's
what my opponent told me after the game
which I still have a hard time believing
but um I I do believe my opponent it's
just it's it's super crazy that uh this
could be true but my opponent told me
after the game that he's seen this exact
position before like this is some part
of his opening preparation that maybe he
looked at a while ago and he spent all
his time trying to remember what what's
happening after the exchange sack mainly
What's happen happening after Queen
takes E6 and I was shocked that he took
all his time to to get to a position
that he knew but um yeah sometimes this
is what happens in chess when you study
so many different opening lines before a
game or probably in my opponent's case
he did not review this line before the
game now of course I had no clue about
this during the game I had no clue my
opponent had seen this position before
maybe had some idea with the engine
evaluation could be and in this position
I was trying to play for a win I really
wanted to pressure my opponent on the
clock and even though my king is quite
exposed I I thought I have enough
resources to defend here now the move I
played was Rook to E8 attacking the
queen I thought this is the most natural
move he plays Queen G6 and I play Rook
to E7 just a more useful Square for The
Rook over defending the bishop maybe
giving my king some path to run away in
the future and here my opponent plays
Bishop to
D3 and in this position uh my opponent
is below 2 minutes but I took a very
long think here trying to figure out
what to do next and I realized that
black doesn't really have too many
candidate moves it's actually very
difficult to find a reasonable move here
for black now there's a a tricky move H5
that bre briefly crossed my mind um but
I pretty quickly dismissed this move
even though it has the idea if Queen
takes G5 Bishop H6 wins the queen uh but
there's this move Knight takes G5 and I
was fantasizing about sacking my queen
and then winning it back but in the
resulting position yeah white has three
pawns and a bishop for a rook so this is
not good at all for black so going back
H5 was out of the question I was mainly
considering Knight D7 and Knight D5 uh
cuz really no other piece has a great
move here and I really wanted to play
Knight D7 but the drawback of this move
is it allows Bishop C4 given the Knight
is no longer controlling the C4 square
and this bishop is just piercing through
the position and I thought uh yeah white
has ideas of like taking and if takes
there's takes and takes and checkmates
there's also ideas of Rook E1 to remove
my rook and getting Queen F7 Checkmate
and Meanwhile my queen is pretty much
sidelined and white has ideas also bring
the knight in so I thought Knight D7 is
way too risky and after a long think I
opted for the move Knight to D5 uh after
thinking for about half an hour and the
benefit of this move is it's a bit more
centralizing I'm pressuring the Knight
on C3 uh but the draw of this move is it
allows this move Queen F5 check because
my knight is obstructing my queen from
controlling F5 another drawback with
Knight D5 is it gives up control over
the C8 Square so after I play King E8 my
opponent plays Queen
C8 and we go from what's like a really
complicated and messy looking position
to ending the game game in three-fold
repetition and the game ended here
basically um yeah king8 position has
occurred three times and after just 26
moves the game ended in a
draw and I really wanted to push for a
win especially given the time situation
I just didn't see an opportunity to do
so and I'm really really curious to see
if stockfish
had any improvements for me actually
before I run the engine analysis I want
to just make a note cuz my opponents
told me after the game that he was
considering declining the three-fold uh
he was considering playing the move
Bishop to
B5 which did not even cross my mind
during the game but uh I think this
would have been like a cold shower maybe
if if he played this move move uh it's
just such a ridiculous looking move
putting the bishop where it can just be
taken by the pawn but of course the
point is if I take the bishop his Knight
comes in and yeah this looks actually
really good for white and if I play a
move uh like Knight takes
C3 I lose my queen because there's
tactics along the fifth Rank and there's
also some crazy lines like if I play
King d8 then
he can take and then take and then take
and then here and then here and then
here and then here he's winning The Rook
so also if King C8 there's uh there's
Bishop D7 winning the queen so we were
talking about all these lines after the
game and we didn't actually reach a
conclusion what black should do if white
plays Bishop
B5 so I think now is a time to check
with the engine and and yeah as usual I
will click the
button as we wait for the engine to
Crunch uh friendly reminder do have a
merch promotion going on use coupon code
Qatar to save 15% off all merch at
shop.on rosen.com here we go okay let's
see the
graph wow so my opponent played a
perfect
game I made one in
accuracy wow so another like very clean
game but my opponent was like much
better at some
point so let's see it looks like this
was a critical moment so I was supposed
to play Bishop E6 according to the
engine although I guess there's a lot of
like playable options here like d takes
E4 definitely a playable move and let's
see let's see what stockfish says so
Queen a A5 apparently gives white some
Edge but sometimes you can't always
trust the engine at a low depth if we go
forward is it actually better for
white we played into the most critical
line so my opponent was supposed to play
Queen D6 check which was actually what I
was expecting I was going to play Rook
E7
here um and somehow white is maybe
slightly for choice but after
Queen
G6 yeah so if if anyone wants to play
for a
win it's white I guess Knight E5 is the
way to do it so real quick what's
happening after Bishop
B5 Knight B4
ah my opponent actually mentioned this
move after the game Knight B4 is
insane cuz I pin the bishop and if takes
looks like White's winning the queen but
I take back and defend my
queen
wow like B4 is the only move too to like
not be
worse okay so Bishop E5 wasn't a great
option for white but Knight E5 I was
after Knight 5 what was I going to do I
just going to take
it and then I can't take on
C3 yeah this would have been scary of
course it would have been risky for my
opponent to play on with the time
situation
wow so yeah this was a pretty short game
but
uh yeah still crazy like some of these
variations are are hard to
digest so I think a draw is a fair
result I I really was never better this
game uh if anything like my position was
very very
precarious so okay happy to to walk away
with a draw um hope people enjoyed this
one I'm still shocked that my
opponent had seen this position before
after king
f8 um basically how many moves a prep
like 18 moves of prep for my
opponent I assume he's seen Queen digs
E6 before too but um yeah anyway uh
thanks everyone for watching if you have
questions or comments about this game
leave them below and stay tuned for
three more rounds of Chess uh be sure to
check out the twitch Channel twitch.tv/
amrosen Jonathan TR is doing commentary
of all the rounds and also stay tuned
for more Recaps and I'll see you guys
soon